Oh what is going on my little duty
stains Oh now since we started triple F
a lot of you guys have been going on
this journey with me and I want to thank
you all out there and congratulate you
guys on your progress and limite
something it might - oh no hat buddy
that's right people the purpose of
triple F was to motivate and keep us
accountable and yes I think it's been a
working gun shooter bimyou
now recently a subscriber asked me to go
ahead and talk about the topic of
excuses why you don't go to the gym
while you don't want to work out in
etcetera so let's go ahead and roll
through this now when it comes to living
a healthier lifestyle I have heard the
same type of crap from the same type of
people and how do I know this you ask is
because I'm talking about myself for
example here's a common excuse that I
always used to say man you know me or
Kevin's way like they're our big bounty
did they dig in [ __ ] bay-buh [ __ ] you
got normal ass bones you've got a lot of
[ __ ] and fat around it what the [ __ ] I
have never heard of somebody look at the
modern human skeleton and say as you can
see this [ __ ] got big bones because of
course it has nothing to do with your
diet and your lifestyle
it has everything to do with your bones
you know sadly enough this is a common
thing that a lot of us tend to do we
always find something to use as a crutch
so we could use that as an excuse to
stay the way that we are another excuse
that I constantly hear is well fatness
runs in my genes and in my veins I can't
help it
ah no butter and sell your thighs run
through your genes but this is upset
because I used to always love playing
the victim card reason being is because
playing the victim has always been a lot
easier than making the right choices
when you choose to sit back and do
nothing you're not really being held
accountable for [ __ ] so you don't really
have that responsibility which means
that your alleviating a feeling bad if
you fail for those of you out there who
are struggling with this let me go ahead
and break this down for you like this a
lot of the things that you want like
you're going to have to work hard for so
why would your fitness be any different
you know just like me you sit there and
you pity yourself and you tell yourself
you are the way you are because the
circumstances beyond your control but
really think about it is it once again
for those of you out there that are
struggling
I want you guys to ask yourself this
question why is it that everything and
everyone is to blame but yourself for me
it was because I really didn't want that
responsibility and you guys know me I'm
a grade-a hater oh man there was
somebody thin around me I hated that
[ __ ] guts look at that [ __ ] walking
around with his muscle Betty beats his
wife mmm he goes the gym you already
know he kidnapped babies I said I'm
gonna tell to you like this eventually
you are gonna run out of excuses and
find yourself in a place that you are
going to hate and trust me the people
around you are gonna hate hearing them
as well and once again this only applies
to people who are verbally out there
telling us that they want to lose weight
but they're not really doing anything
about it you know if you're big or out
of shape or small or whatever you know
you like that
all you men go out with your bad self
and I think I really understand why I
even got this requested do this video
because honestly we you know people get
tired of hearing your [ __ ] [ __ ]
have a positive group around you stop
saying that you're gonna [ __ ] do it
and just do it
actions always speak louder than words
especially when it comes to working out
because you gotta move your [ __ ] body
I know that there's a huge handful you
out there that are like oh I'm trying to
lose weight and I'm not losing weight I
don't know why well that's because your
body is not like everybody else's you
have the fine-tuning to figure out what
works for you so because once again you
guys have been asking so much and you're
so curious about my progress and you
can't tell the videos a lot of people
have been telling me that physically
I've lost a lot of weight I don't really
[ __ ] know because I see this [ __ ]
face every day
as of today while checking the scale I
have lost a total of 21 pounds that's
right
I still have a long way to go the number
doesn't really matter to me but um yeah
it does make me feel pretty good so
remember Fitness fam life is always what
you make it but it's up to you to take
what you deserve let's go for broke Oh
what is going on my YouTube fellas look
at this uppercut boxing boxing crack you
in the face I'm not scary but anyways
this concludes another episode of triple
F and I want to thank you guys for
coming with me on this journey and I
lost these 21 pounds because you all
have been supporting me so I hope I'm
doing the same for you now remember if
you are making your videos make sure you
tweet me every week about you doing
videos so the only way you can tweet me
is if you obviously follow me on Twitter
which is at Davis o comedy and remember
to follow me on Instagram if you want
other updates and you just want to know
about my life that's also at Davis o
comedy
bing-bang-boom remember people go for
broke apparel to is gonna end their
winter floor season real suit and spring
will be starting up so make sure you go
ahead and copy a gear go for broke
apparel commas at the link below
so yes Fitness fam I will see you guys
next Wednesday and of course you have
your regular viewing pleasure videos on
Sunday as well I will see y'all later
peace out what's up Chris walk all day
chumosh it off now since we started whoa
period now since we started at a set of
modern human and a set of modern human
skeleton that's right speak some [ __ ]
English it's America okay right uh hello
as you know the [ __ ] we always find
something to use yeah I don't know about
that oh yeah when you choose to sit back
and do nothing about the situation that
you're in you're not really feeling
bleep feeling you're not in it you don't
not really been Mother Russia when you
sit when you sit back and you choose to
do nothing you're not really being held
accountable for anything for darlin